اضافه للتوترات السياسيه والعسكريه
المحتمله اثار تقرير وكاله بلومبرج اليوم
مخاوف من سباق تسلح نووي الوكاله قالت ان
روسيا صدرت ما يقرب من سبعه اعضاف كميه
اليورانيوم عالي التخصيب الى الصين خلال
الفتره ما بين سبتمبر وديسمبر من العام
الماضي بحسب تم تصدير هذه المواد من روسيا
الى الصين لاستخدامها في مفعل جديد بجزيره
تشامبياو النائيه ما يتيح القدره على
انتاج بلوتونيوم يمكن استخدامه لاحقا في
الاسلحه النوويه
نقلت في تقريرها عن مسؤولي مخابرات
امريكيين توقعهم انه عندما يبدا العمل
بالمفاعل الصيني هذا العام فسيكون بوسع
بيكين زياده مخزون رؤوس الحربيه النوويه
بنحو اربعه اضعاف في السنوات الاثني عشر
المقبله اذا المقصود الاعوام المقبله وهو
ما من شانه ان يسمح للصين بمضاهات
الترسانه النوويه التي تنشرها الولايات
المتحده وروسيا حاليا
تاتي مساعد الصين لتوسيع اسلحه هذا الذريه
في وقت تتعرض فيه المعاهده التي تحد من
المخزونات الاستراتيجيه لكل من الولايات
المتحده وروسيا لخطر الانهيار في ظل الحرب
على اوكرانيا